sobre todo en lo económico menos
desempleo mayores oportunidades para los
costarricenses y si hacia el final de su
discurso hizo algunas tormentas
concretas una de ellas fue el primer
compromiso político como presidente
electo será detener la discriminación y
el acoso contra todas las mujeres en
todos los ámbitos del país estas son las
palabras de rodrigo chávez ahora
presidente de la república y lo dice
cuando justamente en estos momentos de
hacer una pequeña manifestación de
personas que se pronunciaban en contra
de la cosa sexual el machismo y la
misoginia otra de las promesas que hizo
fue en mayor inclusión para los pueblos
originarios o fondos indígenas y que no
se retrocederá en materia de derechos
humanos de la población el inclemente
twitter también lanzó algunas
advertencias en contra del crimen
organizado y el narcotráfico
mayor seguridad para la ciudadanía epc